[Music]
welcome back today we're incredibly
lucky to be joined by Rene Alma Ling
Rene is a professor of sociology and
public health at Yale University and
she's one of the world's leading experts
on the market for sperm and egg Rene
thank you so much for joining us it's a
pleasure to be here so Rene you're an
expert on the buying and selling of
sperm and eggs sometimes also referred
to as gametes and we're gonna talk a
little bit about those two markets and
we're gonna start by talking just a bit
about sperm step a little about who's
the typical sperm donor in America I
mean the average sperm donor is a
college student eyes in his early 20s
he's interested in making a little bit
of extra money at a job that doesn't
take too much of his time when I did
interviews with sperm donors I found
that there were really two groups there
was this group of sort of younger
college students there was also a group
of older men who had known somebody who
experienced trouble getting pregnant or
infertility and so some of those folks
had sort of put in some of their energy
into being sperm donors as well and a
lot of this is from your amazing book
sex cells cels which i think is one of
the best titles i've seen in the
academic market how much is a typical
sperm donor paid in America yeah well
the average payment is about $100 $125
per sample what most people don't know
about sperm banks is that men go through
an extensive screening process and then
they're going in at least once a week
for six months to a year in order to
earn that 100 to 125 dollars per sample
so we have this idea that men can wake
up one morning and say oh I'm gonna go
donate sperm this morning and go make 50
bucks and that's not really how it works
and so the screening screens that a lot
of men any sense about like how many men
get screened out I have to say for my
class when I taught this in a
bricks-and-mortar class once I tried to
become a sperm donor
I was screened out I don't know what
that says about me am i normal to
inventor what kind of number of people
get screened out yeah well you're in
very good company goodness so about 99%
of men who apply to become sperm donors
will be screened out so sperm banks are
looking for men who are extremely
fertile with very high sperm counts so
if you look at a sort of bell curve of
fertility they're looking for men in the
two to three percent of sperm count
that's because they freeze the sperm or
cryopreserve it that kills off about
half the cells so that's right there
knocking out most men who apply and then
the men who make it through that test
need three generations of their family
health history to look pretty good so
men who have you know a lot of heart
attacks or mental illness or alcoholism
in their family won't make it through
the screening process and then they have
to be willing to go in at least once a
week for a year to make donations and so
you know if you have a hundred men who
make that first call to the sperm bank
you're really walking out the door with
about one percent of the people making
it through that process so there's a lot
of screening that happens and I know
you've written your work about how men
are paid so just because I donate sperm
does that mean I automatically get paid
for that donation no it doesn't so in
sperm banks men go in and they make this
donation if their sperm count is high
enough to meet the bank standards then
they will be paid for that donation but
all kinds of things can cause that sperm
count to drop including being too
stressed out say by your finals in
school if you're drinking too much
alcohol if you're not getting enough
rest if you're sick so all of these
things can cause sperm count to drop so
men's sperm count which you know another
thing that people don't realize is men
sperm count really fluctuates over days
and months and so sperm donors have to
stay pretty healthy and take good care
of themselves in order to actually make
that money from being a donor and
there's also an abstinence requirement
as I understand it yes so men who donate
sperm because they need to build up that
sperm count have to be abstinent from
any sort of sexual activity for about 48
hours before they go donate so then you
can start to understand how sperm donors
find this a little bit onerous they have
to schedule their sex lives they have to
be mindful of their diet and their
exercise and so if they're going in to
donate once a week then they're being
abstinent for two days before they go in
if they're trying to donate twice a week
then they're absent for two days twice a
week and some of the donors I
interviewed tried to donate three times
a week so then they're really sort of
really scheduling their sex lives in a
way that many of them did find somewhat
onerous and I should say that although
we're using the term donation and
because that's the common term as both
of us have written about in our work
there's lots of controversy about
whether that's the
right terms people for provision which
is more neutral some people like to say
sale because it is kind of being
compensated at least the portion that
we're talking about we'll keep using the
word donation because it's more natural
but always good to kind of acknowledge
the way in which these terms carry
meaning it's an interesting point and
there has been a lot of debate in the
literature as you note for me as a
sociologist I'm really interested in how
this industry thinks of itself and how
it works and so it's important to me
that the term that they use is donation
and then of course we can sit here and
say well you're being paid for donation
and a paid donation seems a little
oxymoronic but I think it's important to
understand why they use that language
how that language functions and
organizing the market and shaping donors
experiences and this leads into the
question about how men are recruited so
how are sperm donors recruited what's
the messaging about sperm donation tell
me a little bit more about that yeah
well historically sperm banks really
relied on this idea that sperm donation
was this easy thing it's something
that's a little bit funny you know they
make jokes in their advertisements and
so the advertisements really focus on
cartoon images of sperm there might be
some small print about helping somebody
to become a family but the focus is
really on you know come in and get paid
for something you're already doing to
quote one of the ads so they draw on
these sort of cheeky advertisements in
order to recruit men in because they're
dealing with the college-age population
for the most part but donation is not
really framed for men as something that
is important or you know really
contributing to the lives of others by
helping them have families the focus
really is on come in and you know
provide some sperm and get paid so let's
talk a little bit about the way in which
these men are recruited and in
particular sort of gendered messaging in
the croute meant and the conceptions of
employment and this is a really
important part of your work I know
really the main argument of my book is
that this language of donation suffuses
both the world of egg agencies and sperm
banks but in sperm banks a paved
donation is understood as a job they
think of men as employees they cut them
paychecks every two weeks they talk to
them about this is something they need
to show up for on a regular basis clock
in and clock out and produce a passable
sample
and an egg donation that paid donation
is really understood as a gift from one
woman to another and that it's in a gift
in the service of creating a family so
even though this language of donation is
similar across sperm donation and egg
donation what that donation is it looks
really different
how long do men typically stay sperm
donors you know we actually don't have
any data to answer that question so one
of the things that I think we'll
probably talk about later is the fact
that this market is completely
unregulated in the United States we have
no idea how many donors there are how
often they donate how many children are
born so those basic questions we
actually don't have the answers to and
let me just emphasize that last point
you said that we don't know how many
children are born there are no
regulations so in theory there's no
limit to the number of children that
could be born from a certain door now
many of the clinics will say that
they're responsible about this they keep
registries oh there's some question
about whether people can go to more than
one registry right right well sperm
banks do ask their clients to report
back if they have a pregnancy if they
give birth to a child so that they can
keep track of how many offspring have
been born per donor but they don't have
any way of enforcing that reporting and
there's also no standards or regulations
for what the maximum is for that family
so we now have websites like donor
sibling registry com where people can go
and see that particular donor from a
particular sperm bank has 40 offspring
who have registered just with that
website or 75 or a hundred and 75 so we
do have some of these anecdotal reports
of very large numbers of children being
born from particular donors and that to
me is one of the major things that we do
need to rectify in this market yeah one
of the concerns with sometimes called
accidental incest that you might
actually end up having a romantic
relationship with a half-sibling at
least right yeah I think that's one you
know that is definitely one of the
theoretical concerns that has been out
there I'm actually more concerned about
the health effects because a lot of
these donors are young college students
and they may have genetic mutations that
will cause disease later in life that
they may not know about and so there
have been cases such as one that was
ported in the Journal of the American
Medical Association with a donor who
didn't realize that he had this heart
condition
that was genetic in his heritable
condition he was a sperm donor he had 22
children and 6 or 7 of those kids
inherited that mutation including a
toddler who died from it so in old
fashioned normal reproduction you know
men could certainly have 2 or 5 or even
you know eight or ten children but when
we ramped up the numbers as we have with
sperm donation those unknown health
risks that get passed on get passed on
to a potentially much larger number of
children and we'll actually talk about a
case later in the course about a child
who inherits polycystic kidney disease
and tries to track down the identity of
the sperm donor for that purpose